these are just some of the nurses
doctors health and social care
assistants all who've sacrificed their
lives to save ours the black Asian and
minority ethnic workforce in the NHS are
being hit hard by this deadly virus and
we need to know why this is the man
tasked with tackling racial inequality
within the health services workforce the
fact that a high number of black and
minority ethnic staff are dying from
this pandemic is a worry for us it's a
challenge for us but we need to rise to
that challenge and what we need to do is
look at what we can put in place right
now to support our staff dr. Naqvi
believes a lot of the be AME workforce
have a different work ethic a more
hands-on approach he said and that right
now could be a huge downfall what we do
know is that every member of our NHS
workforce is absolutely committed to
patient care but there may be parts of
the workforce that see working in the
NHS as more of a vocation than an
occupation our analysis shows 72 percent
of all health and social care staff
who've died with Kovach 19 are from a b
AME background but make up just 21
percent of the workforce around 19
percent of patients to die in hospitals
in England were from ethnic minorities
or mixed backgrounds but that figure is
proportionate to the population figures
the main difference is among black
African and Caribbean patients but the
numbers here are small and 10 percent of
the data is missing the population
figures are dated and the two regions
with the highest number of deaths London
and the Midlands are also the most
ethnically diverse there are a number of
reasons behind this potential issue we
know that many black and Asian and
minority ethnic people are key workers
whether it's on the front line in our
hospitals driving buses are working in
supermarkets their vulnerability to this
virus could be automatically increased
but the stats show a high number of B
AME families are living in overcrowded
and multi-generational households making
it almost impossible to social distance
and the science is clear that underlying
health conditions
like type-2 diabetes and heart problems
are prevalent in these ethnicities but
further research needs to be done and
today a group of 17 non-executive
directors in the NHS have written to the
government offering their experience and
knowledge as an independent advisory
group we can bring our expertise from
various sectors we can bring our
knowledge of the NHS industry to
perspectives and we can bring that
insight that we have in the Vienna
community you know that knowledge that
that understanding of culture
experiences understanding of culture
intelligence we can bring all of that
together it may be true that the
coronavirus doesn't discriminate between
race class or creed but as the names and
photographs emerge of those who've lost
their lives to kovat 19 the real
life-and-death implications of social
inequality are becoming increasingly
apparent throughout this pandemic in
some am rashid sky news